what do you think women want in men  exactly the opposite of what they're  saying they want right now  honestly there seems to be  a culture of women saying you know i  want this absolutely perfect prince  charming who dotes on me all the time  and is super emotional and is constantly  updating me on his feelings and then  they show their boyfriend it's like this  masculine provider protector who is you  know constantly there for you but  handles problems so  i think that's what women actually want  and what they gravitate towards but what  comes out of the mouth can be  a little different i think  men i don't know if you've noticed but  they're a lot more feminine  these days at least here in la where i  live a lot of very feminine men but i  think women typically look for  an amount of masculinity that usurps  their own so whatever that might be for  you